what drew you all to boy choir and
especially for the director working on a
tight schedule with children and with
music and I just wondered how you could
do this I mean it was a short shooting
schedule my previous films were much
longer shoots like a Red Vine was 65 I
think and I did 55 and I always started
myself as somebody particularly slow and
I walking into this I knew it was to be
fast and again I was a little scared but
in the end I felt that that the going
fast at times were also like we're not
doing period with like it you know it
was a particularly heavy set but I and I
in the end I think there's something on
the screen that comes from going fast
and not thinking so much listen if you
if you have all the time in the world
sometimes you're overthinking in here
like there was none of that and and then
I think the the rush of our the way we
put stuff at sometimes it was really
crazy sometimes there was a number of
times I'm really grateful that the
actors didn't complain so much because I
would have but the but there's an energy
also in like just walking into it and
putting it on the screen and rushing
sometimes into a take with no rear soles
but you know sometimes voluntarily but
like I think there's something of that
on the screen of your marvelous
performances all of you I think the
first time you and I sat down I really
didn't want to get any script notes from
you so I just talked about the music and
hope that that would eat up a couple
hours of time which it did hope then
those would never come
I grew up near the American boy choir
School in New Jersey and that was the
inspiration for the choir you see in
this movie and I was never a singer but
I was always a classical piano player
and was very comfortable with the music
and I don't know that you necessarily
need a musical background to be in this
movie or to create this movie but you do
need a creative background
and so you know the more I thought about
this movie it's more about wrestling
with how to be creative and how to how
to channel that into something that
actually can be realized well I remember
the first time I met with Francois I was
like how am I going to convince him to
hire me that's where I was going in with
and I think we discussed Wooley for
about five minutes
and then he went on to just talk me
through each scene how the music was
going to move through it was like yes
whatever that sounds beautiful like I
will absolutely do it and so we spent an
hour and a half
bonding over how the music was going to
shape the film I was like well this
sounds great I hope hope he likes me the
music is gonna be great like I would
love to be involved and I don't have to
say in terms of like coming from a
musical TV show when we were filming in
New York and it was a long day because
we were doing that big performance at
the end and I walked in there's like
this feels like Glee there's all the big
lights and I remember talking to Deborah
she's like this is so different she's
like it's a whole different setup and I
come from the world where I'm used to
make musical numbers taking an entire
day and like for me I'm like oh yeah
like I brought a bunch of stuff to read
I was like I'm gonna lay back and relax
where I think so maybe some of the other
people didn't know what to expect that
was the part I felt most comfortable
with the rest of it was all new to me
well the truth is that the these
characters are written with words but as
but as well as with music it's
particularly true in the case of Carvel
I think what you're hearing in in the
film the guidelines of that was really
the music that Carvel would play and yes
our own personal tastes matter because
we push it in a direction but there's a
lot of discussions that we had with Judy
Caro in particular we will talk about
the music it's important to skew it and
you want it to be a wide audience but
there's a moment where you you are
dictated the the nature of Carol's work
like like he plays certain music he is
this character so you're right you you
write the characters with music but the
music tell you what music to put in and
then this
for many directors and I had no musical
background whatsoever and so I had to
learn everything in this film at the
real American Blake wear school and it
was a whole new world for me and I had
no clue what I was doing most of the
time but with the help of friends law
and everybody it was just it all fell
into place you know and it was really
really cool being able to be introduced
to that new world and the choral music
and it was insane everything that
happened and what we did so we're not
seeing most of the time so I did sing on
set yes and so I don't I'm not sure
which is my voice but I think some of
those my voice in the film when stet is
kind of like practicing the stuff that's
me and then know most of it like at
Riverside and all that stuff but that's
not me but it was a very talented singer
who sang over me and so they did a great
job it's the stuff that you don't see
that's behind the scenes that's really
what counts and so if you did see me my
voice not matching up with their track
and stuff like that that's that that
takes away from from the film and so
it's very it's it's very intricate what
they did and it's very well done a lot
of sweating when I heard that Francois
wanted me to be in the film I said I'll
get him a coffee you know I had
certainly seen the Red Violin it's one
of my favorites and so I also wanted to
work with Dustin again because Dustin
had given me my first speaking role in a
movie back in 1976 and I was telling
pres was--and system can't be here today
that the last speech he gives the boys
is very much like the Dustin that really
took me by the hand literally and said
here's the camera you know and one time
when we were shooting he could tell I
got very nervous and he said can you
hear Owen setting up the shot and I said
no I can't he said well listen you know
and I started listening and turning my
focus outside myself and the minute I
relaxed he knew and he said that's it he
was so so
corta vandhey so helpful and I think
that's underneath the character of
Carvel he he's so passionate and Dustin
is so passionate about his craft I mean
I've known him ever since then and and
every time we've crossed paths he has
somehow said something to me about the
work and about how I remember seeing you
but the Palm Springs Festival a couple
years ago he was standing offstage and
he said you were in the dark and he said
you know it's about tone
it's about getting exactly the right
tone you know he's just he's so
passionate about it and I really wanted
to experience working with him again
given the tight schedule
I always thought Dustin like to
improvise so was there much
improvisation off the script I was the
one who take most of the blow for that
there was a lot of improv and it was fun
because I'm trained in like to do improv
and stuff so I could kind of go along
with them and the scene where I say I
don't want to be kicked out I know what
I did was wrong everyone was sitting at
the table that was a lot of improv there
beforehand or like get the beats and
stuff that was that was an awesome time
to be with everybody and there's a lot
of yeah you bring in the theme of time
and time becomes the ultimate adversary
it takes your voice it ages you death
etc when did that was that always in the
script I was always there and it made
the whole thing worthwhile to me it
completed the character and made it
different from any other music story out
there because you have this thing that's
really not yours and inhabits you and
it's a great scene that I'm really happy
you kept in where Willy talks to stead
about what it really means to sing at
that age so that was that was always
baked into it that was when I was
reading the script that was my favorite
thing because I grew up singing and when
I got to that point and the script was
like oh I remember that day like in my
life when I was on stage and couldn't
hit the notes anymore and as it quit
why didn't nobody warned me about this
like what is happening to me
and I hadn't seen that done before or
portrayed in that real way and so to be
on the other side of it be able to
portray that to him was a it was like it
was relief to my younger self that never
got that I was fortunate to have a
mentor I went to school at Southern
Methodist when it was becoming a
conservatory and I was lucky to have a
mentor and dr. Hopgood who sat us first
year students down and said it's going
to take you 15 years to do this same as
if you wanted to be a lawyer or a doctor
it's a craft that you have to build you
have to build an audience you have to so
it was taken very seriously and so
that's the way I felt for many many
years and now it it is so fast and it's
something I regret because you know
sometimes you hit it and it's wonderful
or then you can get home and you're
lying in bed and you go I missed that
moment there was something else going on
there and you it's it's it sometimes I
feel that we are photographing something
that's not ready to be photographed yet
but that's just my own curmudgeonly way
of looking at the craft I wrote this
script 18 years ago so it's move was
ready to be photographed